i am loyal empire
to the clionic dynasty above all else
hey guys pete here today i'm gonna talk
about questions for foundation season
two the finale left us with a lot to
think about and i've been reading over
all your comments since i uploaded my
last video trying to get a better idea
of where everyone's at so i'm gonna
throw out what i'm thinking about we'll
talk about it in the comments and it
should go without saying but there will
be spoilers for everything related to
season one i'm also going to be
referring to isaac asimov's book series
the show is based on but i'll try to
avoid spoiling things for people who
haven't read them and with that out of
the way let's get into it i believe the
biggest question from the first season
of foundation is one that was introduced
in the first episode who really blew up
the star bridge politically cleon the
12th who is now brother dusk in the
timeline at the end of the season used
this incident to make an example out of
the planets in nacreon and thespis the
dynasty's official story is that
terrorists from those planets were
responsible this is almost certainly not
what happened but even after an
investigation where demarzel was
traveling around trying to gather
evidence they weren't able to discover
who was responsible early theories on
this from fans were that perhaps it was
demarzel herself this is mostly based on
her being mysterious but also in a
powerful position with access the other
one was that it was harry selden himself
in an effort to speed the fall of the
empire along this event is part of the
reason why the cleons were distracted
and opted on exiling harry selden and
his followers both of these are
possibilities i wouldn't say there's
been any new evidence that seems to
support them one way or the other but i
do think there are some problems with
both in relation to the scale of the
destruction involved the attack killed a
lot of people as the season progressed
we learned about the conspiracy against
the dynasty and i think that has become
the most likely option we know that it's
been in existence for some time and is
organized with some real backing behind
it so that's where i'm currently at
although the question there then becomes
who's responsible for putting this
conspiracy in motion in the first place
one other possibility i think you can
consider after the finale and harry's
revelations to the thespians and
anachrians about the first betrayal is
whether cleon the 12th had something to
do with it himself i think that feels
unlikely if for no other reason then
there are much bigger mysteries
surrounding the cleons for season 2. and
that is the next big question is the
genetic dynasty over in the process of
covering this show i've listened to all
the official podcasts read a lot of
interviews with the cast and the
creators and it seems to me that the
current status of brother day and
brother dusk whether they've been
adulterated is up in the air there's a
part of me that tends to think that the
damage is done either way and that kind
of ties into the question of what was
behind demerizel's decision to kill
brother dawn there was a lot of debate
about whether or not she was trying to
strike back against brother day for what
he had done making her kill halima at
the end of the day what's more important
is that he thinks that's the reason that
she did it and will always be suspicious
of her as a result so to the question is
the genetic dynasty over i think the
answer is yes it's certainly going to go
downhill as a result of what happened
here regardless if there's any pure cli
on the first dna still around or not
as far as demarzel's motivations there
is a question there my impression from
watching the first season is that the
dynasty or possibly more specifically
cleon the first has altered the way
demerizel functions to make her top
priority protecting his legacy it
doesn't necessarily track with
everything from asimov's work which
leaves some people confused on how she
can violate the three laws of robotics
and i don't want to derail on that here
but there is a xeroth law that exists
that's capable of superseding the three
laws and i think demarzel in the show
has a modified xeroth law that does the
same thing for different purposes i do
plan to get into that more in a video
dedicated to demarzel but i think the
show has made the case when she talks
about not having individuated sentience
and a stated inability to go against the
empire's wishes that there's something
interesting going on here and i'm
looking forward to dig into that for the
sake of this video i think the questions
we ought to be asking are what would she
do if she wasn't limited by this what
would her true motivations be and what
are the kinds of things that she could
do to get around it and ultimately free
herself from this situation the fact
that she's tearing her face off in that
last scene of the season seems like a
clear indication that this creates inner
conflict i imagine we'll learn a lot
more about this in the future and
primarily how they were able to alter
her in this way one thing that seems
certain is that someone was able to
override her security and i'm gonna use
that to transition to telling you about
today's sponsor nordpass nordpass just
published new research about the most
commonly used passwords by country and
how long it would take to crack it the
research shows that overall in the us
150 passwords out of the 200 can be
cracked in less than a second if you
found your password on this list make
sure you change it to a unique and
strong one and even if you do better
than one of these if you're anything
like me then you have so many passwords
to remember that's why i use nordpass i
can store all my passwords in one place
there's no need to memorize all of them
and i can access all my logins with a
single master password i use it to
automatically generate secure passwords
the more complex the password the safer
the account is that means none of my
passwords will show up on that list
nordpass is the new generation password
manager where security meets simplicity
and it's got great features like
password health which you can use to
check if your passwords are weak older
than 90 days or used for several
accounts and they're currently offering
my viewers a special cyber month deal
get 70 percent off nordpass at
nordpass.com
pete peppers or use the code pete
peppers when you sign up plus you get an
additional month for free this deal is
available until the 1st of december 2021
so you'll want to act now beyond trantor
and the genetic dynasty another big
question i have is what's going to
happen to the foundation now that they
know harry is inside the vault when he
mentioned that he was developing the
narrative to gail and essentially making
himself a martyr that makes me wonder
how that changes when he returns as a
sentient ai in the finale for the record
i don't think he'll be involved with the
day-to-day dealings on terminus or very
regularly at all but his very existence
seems like it might have a great effect
to cut to the chase will this have a
messianic role the showrunner mentioned
one of the things we can expect to see
in season 2 is the church of the
galactic spirit initially i thought this
might be related to a religious
storyline from the books but i'm kind of
leaning towards a church of harry after
the finale he died and came back albeit
in a different form and he is
responsible for crafting the plan that
they're all following and in relation to
the ai it does seem like it's been
confirmed that the version of harry in
the vault is independent to the one that
gail interacted with on the raven two
different harrys that aren't connected
in any way with an indication that the
one on the ship was corrupted when it
was being uploaded to be honest one
other question i have is whether the
raven survived at all when gail is
leaving in the cryopod in the reflection
there's a clear explosion you can see
but it was never explicitly stated that
his trip to helicon ended there even if
that's the case she brought the knife
along which i suppose is a backup copy
and i do think they're gonna play around
with this idea of there being two
different harrys
and that does bring up the question of
what's going to happen next for gail and
salvore to me it seems like they're
indicating that their mentality
abilities which are noticeably different
than what exists in the books has the
ability to draw them together another
important part here is that salvor
brought the prime radiant that's the
last thing we see in the season is her
handing that over to gail that seems to
be a big indication that whatever they
do is going to include psycho history
and i guess it depends on what happened
to harry in his trip to helicon but he
did plant the seeds of the second
foundation with her and that has to come
from somewhere i know there's some other
ideas out there based on different
characters that come up in later books
that would all be kind of spoiler talk
but no matter what they do it's going to
be interesting to see how they get out
of synax now that they're there and
they're pretty far ahead in the timeline
and we have to imagine that things would
have changed significantly on terminus
in that time those are kind of the
biggest questions i had there's little
ones there too like what's going on with
the shadow master i mentioned in one of
my previous videos how he shows up in
the first episode and then we see him
again 35 years later where he looks
exactly the same this is a world where
we have at least one robot and a handful
of clones so he might fit into one of
those categories but i don't think we
got any more evidence about what's going
on with him at all another big question
i have from the history of things is
what are these robot wars that they've
alluded to at different times it sounds
like they came to an end during cleon
the first reign they're a part of the
mural harry mentioned an apple orchard
in episode 2 that was older than the
imperial gardens where they used to hang
ai sympathizers the showrunner did say
we would go back in time in future
seasons and i hope we'll learn more
about how those wars played out i had
some questions about the timeline
considering that we jumped ahead with
gail and salvor at the end of the season
i don't think that means that we'll pick
up there for sure after all there were
multiple timelines in season one but it
is a possibility
the first book in the series jumps
decades between each story so when we
next see terminus and trantor we might
just visit them at a different phase of
their existence i do wonder about the
galactic council that dust mentioned in
the finale that hints that the genetic
dynasty has some accountability rather
than an absolute rule and i doubt that
was in there as a throwaway line i think
we were supposed to pick up on that and
i think it means that we're gonna find
out who they are in the next season and
i think that is probably a good place to
leave things there are a lot of little
questions and we can talk about those in
the comments just to throw it out there
there are a lot of hand wavy things in
this series a few things that don't
necessarily add up and you're free to
discuss that but i tended not to focus
there because i don't think it makes for
the most interesting things to think
about but at the same time i'm not
completely overlooking that stuff and
i'm hoping they improve on that in
future seasons so let me know in the
comments what do you think the dynasty
will do next what's going on with
demerizel do you think she's trying to
be free what do you think gail and
salvore will do over there on cynix and
how do you think things will change from
the foundation now that they know what's
inside the vault please like this video
if you enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon